Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dave from
Mesquite, Texas. Dave from Mesquite, Texas.
Dave from Mesquite, Texas, Welcome to the program.
If you unmute yourself, I will be
able to hear you, Dave, please.
And last chance for Dave from Mesquite, Texas.
Speaker 3: Hi, Mr. Packer. Good to
talk with you. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you now. Dave, welcome.
Speaker 3: Sorry about that. No problem. I live
in a suburb of Dallas. Obviously, it's kind of
a small town. There's a bunch of churches here,
and I kind of had a question about churches and
tax status. Sure. Taxed the tax exempt status. So
these churches, a lot of them are pretty lavish
in their on really nice pieces of property here.
Yeah, I would think at some point the city would
be disincentivized to have these churches
here because, you know, they're not. Well,
the local governments are getting the the
property tax. The state certainly isn't
from these churches being here.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I just don't really
know what can be done, because if places start
rejecting churches on the basis that they'd rather
have someone there who will pay taxes, I think
it becomes a constitutional issue pretty quickly.
Certainly the churches will make it one. I think
it's complicated. The math of it completely
checks out, but I just don't know that that's
something that they could easily get away with.
Yeah. Not to mention, by the way, I mean, I think
you also have to consider I don't know much about
Mesquite, Texas, but my guess is there's a lot of
religious people there, too. Right. It's not just
that. There's churches, there's Christians.
Speaker 3: Yeah it's definitely the Bible
belt. There's it's yeah it's
overwhelmingly Christian church.
Speaker 1: And so my point is you might
not get revenue from the churches,
but there's probably people that live there to be
near the churches and they do pay taxes, you know.
Speaker 3: Now. That's true. Well, great. Thanks
for that. Another quick real question that kind
of is not to do with politics or churches or tax,
but you and producer have such great chemistry.
You guys have to be buds outside of this part of
the show. Is that is that an accurate assessment?
Speaker 1: Absolutely. We actually ride a tandem
bike regularly, and whenever Pat comes to visit in
New York, we can be seen on the streets. We wear
the same outfit and we have a tandem bike. I do
ride in the front, I will admit, but absolutely.
Speaker 3: Tandem bike, not two, but love it.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks, Dave, very much.
Appreciate it. Hey, by the way, Mesquite, I don't
really understand these Dallas suburbs. Does
does Mesquite have its own downtown? Of sorts?
Speaker 3: There's the old historic part
of Mesquite. It's an old railroad town,
so the mesquite trees were used to fuel
the locomotives back in the day. So it's
like an old depot town that kind of got into
cotton farming and kind of grew up from there.
Speaker 1: But where I'm looking at Mesquite
on a map, it's not like near the Chick-Fil-A,
is it? Like where is the downtown?
Speaker 3: So the downtown is going to
be Davis between Davis and Main Street,
kind of between Galloway and Beltline.
Speaker 1: GAL Well, I don't find any of this.
This is crazy. All right. Well, I'm to look into
it more closely. I want to learn all about MySQL.
I'm interested in these Texas suburbs. You know,
they're just so different geographies.
Speaker 3: Our geography is amazing
here. You'd love the the vibe.
Speaker 1: All right. Well,
I will have to get down there soon.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks, Dave. There's
Dave from Mesquite, Texas, with some very,
very powerful declarations. We
are going to speak to more people,
but after a very short break. So
if you're holding on to talk to me,
don't hang up. We're going right
back to the discord lines in a moment